aquí tenemos una masa que está sobre una
superficie sin fricción que está
conectada con un resorte que a su vez
está conectado a la pared lo que haremos
será comprimir el resorte hasta
posicionar la masa en el punto a antes
de hacer esto vemos que la masa está en
la posición cero así que comprimimos el
resorte para dejar la masa en la
posición
y cuando el tiempo sea igual a cero
vamos a soltar la masa pueden imaginar
lo que va a pasar después con esta masa
sobre una superficie sin fricción va a
oscilar entre la posición
y la posición - a ese movimiento lo
hemos expresado aquí con esta gráfica de
posición con respecto al tiempo comienza
en la posición
luego oscila a la izquierda hasta llegar
a la posición menos a y luego oscila
hacia la derecha hasta regresar a la
posición a y así sucesivamente esto se
repite infinitamente si estamos en un
mundo sin fricción y sin resistencia al
aire lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo
será pensar cómo se relaciona esto con
la energía con la información que
tenemos vamos a pensar en la energía
potencial elástica recuerden que cuando
el tiempo es cero la masa está en la
posición
está comprimido este es un sistema masa
resorte y vamos a suponer que no hay
energía que se agregue o se quite al
sistema en el tiempo cero cuando está
comprimido el resorte el sistema más a
resorte va a tener cierta energía
potencial elástica que vamos a dibujar
acá qué va a pasar cuando soltemos el
resorte el resorte va a empujar a la
masa y la va a acelerar hacia la
izquierda y justo cuando la masa pase
por la posición x igual a cero que en la
gráfica indica que ocurre cuando t es
igual a un segundo toda la energía
potencial elástica se habrá convertido
en energía cinética así que la energía
potencial estará acá y qué ocurre cuando
la masa comienza a hacer desacelerada
por el resorte y llega a la posición
- y al llegar a la posición menos a qué
ocurre cuando t es igual a 2 segundos
volvemos a tener la máxima energía
potencial elástica esto se asocia con
estar en la posición menos pueden ver
qué es lo que pasa aquí cuando el tiempo
es igual a 3 segundos toda esa energía
potencial se habrá convertido en energía
cinética a los 4 segundos
regresa la masa a la posición
y de nuevo tenemos solamente energía
potencial por lo que la gráfica de
energía potencial va a lucir así noten
que jamás tenemos energía negativa y qué
pasa con la energía cinética ya nos
hemos referido a ella pero vamos a verla
con más detalle veamos cómo se comporta
la energía cinética con respecto al
tiempo cuando el tiempo es cero y la
masa está en la posición y no hay
movimiento alguno por lo que no tenemos
energía cinética después la masa se
acelerará conforme la energía potencial
se transforma en energía cinética de
manera que tendremos la máxima cantidad
de energía cinética
cuando la masa pasa por la posición cero
la primera vez que pasa por la posición
cero es cuando el tiempo es igual a un
segundo así que aquí tenemos el máximo
de energía cinética cuando el tiempo es
igual a 2 la masa está en la posición
menos a y durante ese instante la
velocidad es igual a 0 por lo que no
tenemos energía cinética xilográfica mos
podemos ver que se intercambia la
energía potencial y la energía cinética
conforme la masa oscila entre la
posición
y la posición menos
la primera vez que estudiamos la energía
y la ley de la conservación de la
energía vimos que si tenemos un sistema
cerrado donde no agregamos o quitamos
energía de dicho sistema como en este
sistema mecánico que tenemos aquí donde
no hay fuerzas disipador as entonces la
energía mecánica se va a conservar si
decimos que la energía mecánica total
del sistema
es igual a la energía potencial que en
este caso es energía potencial elástica
más la energía cinética esto debe ser
constante y en efecto esto se cumple si
vemos la gráfica y sumamos la energía
existente en cualquier momento del
tiempo es decir sumamos ambas curvas
vamos a tener como resultado algo que
luce así como una línea constante
esta es la gráfica de la energía
potencial mecánica del sistema una
pregunta interesante sería ver qué pasa
si tenemos fuerzas disipadores en el
sistema cómo se vería esto si tenemos
fuerzas disipadores como la fricción y
la resistencia al aire entonces la masa
comenzará en la posición a pero quizá no
alcance a llegar a la posición menos
sigue con menos velocidad y tampoco
alcanza a regresar a la posición
y cada vez recorre una menor distancia
si queremos ver qué pasa en este caso
con la energía del sistema la energía
mecánica total del sistema va a
disminuir con el tiempo a dónde va el
resto de la energía pues se va a
transformar en energía térmica debido a
las fuerzas disipador as como la
fricción y la resistencia al aire así
que la energía total disminuye esto
restringe la oscilación de las energías
potencial elástica y cinética del
sistema por ejemplo en esta situación la
energía cinética se verá así donde los
picos estarán restringidos por esta
energía mecánica total hasta aquí
llegamos en este vídeo y espero que con
esto comprendan mejor cómo se relacionan
entre sí la energía cinética y la
energía potencial en relación con la
conservación de la energía especialmente
en sistemas masa resorte
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo